متظاهرون خارج
شركة الكهرباء اللبنانية يشعلون
الشموع ويلعنون الظلام
[موسيقى]
اليوم كم ساعة من الكهرباء
لديك اليوم
أربع ساعات أزهار
حددت المكان الذي أطلق فيه علي محمد الحك 61 عاما
النار وقتل نفسه على ما يبدو في
يأس مثل اللبنانيين  دخل الاقتصاد
في حالة من الانهيار الشديد
لشعبي ، لأن هذا الرجل كان جائعًا ، حيث قام هذا الرجل
بمظاهرة تجمع
بعد أن قتل علي نفسه في شارع الحمرا في بيروت الذي كان رائجًا في
السابق
، اتخذ الآخرون نهجًا أكثر عنفًا
للتعبير عن غضبهم من
تدهور مستويات المعيشة. ما
تراه الآن هو  ليست أزمة ، إنها
انهيار ،
الخبير الاقتصادي ديما كرام يتابع مفاوضات
لبنان
غير المثمرة حتى الآن مع
صندوق النقد الدولي بشأن
خطة الإنقاذ
في أكتوبر من العام الماضي ، اندلعت احتجاجات على مستوى البلاد
حيث بدأ القطاع المصرفي في لبنان
في الانهيار ، وكان ذلك بناءً على ما
وصفه الاقتصاديون بخطة بونزي.
حيث قدمت البنوك اللبنانية
معدلات فائدة مرتفعة للغاية لمعظم اللبنانيين
المودعين في الشتات
ثم استخدموا تلك الودائع لتمويل
العجز الحكومي المتضخم ،
إنه انهيار لنموذج كامل ، إنه
انهيار لنموذج تراكمت عليه
الخسائر على مدى ثلاثة
عقود ، والآن
تتحمل الغالبية العبء الأكبر من هذا الانهيار على
عكس
الانهيار.  النسبة المئوية التي استفادت من هذا النظام
وحققت مبلغًا لا نهائيًا
من الدولارات
في الأشهر الأخيرة ،
فقد ارتفعت الأسعار والبطالة بشكل كبير
، حيث فقدت الليرة الكثير من
قيمتها
طوال اليوم الذي كنت أعمل فيه ولم
أكسب سوى تسعة آلاف  قادة مثل
سائق سيارة الأجرة هذا
في هذا اليوم الذي كان حوالي
دولار
واحد فقط قبل عام ، كان ستة
جزارين أه لا يستطيعون تغطية نفقاتهم ،
قد أغلق الباب ، يقول إنه لا توجد
مبيعات
كل ما يقوله من الأكياس البلاستيكية
إلى الورق الذي يلفه  أصبح اللحم
باهظ الثمن في
[الموسيقى]
عبر متاجر بيروت أغلقت أي
نشاط تجاري
ولا طاقة ولا أمل في
يومين كان لدينا أكثر من 20
ساعة من انقطاع التيار الكهربائي يوميًا
وكان ذلك  القسوة الشديدة علينا في
إبقاء الأضواء في المستشفى الحكومي الرئيسي في بيروت
هو أمر واحد فقط يبقي المخرج الدكتور
فراس أبيض مستيقظًا ليلاً ، حيث
تتزايد حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا هنا بينما
تتبخر الموارد إذا أصبح الوضع
أكثر صعوبة والظهور
في الوقت الحالي هو أنه  قد يصبح الأمر
أكثر صعوبة
سواء كنا
سنستمر في إيجاد الحلول وإجابتي
في هذه اللحظة هي أنني لا أعرف بالنسبة
لأولئك الذين وصلوا إلى الحضيض ،
فإن القمامة هي الملاذ الأخير
في لبنان ولا أحد لديه إجابات